ils sont sûrement l'avenir de l'escrime
française à gauche de la piste jeromi
npanjanga à droite Cédrick enken
champion de France junior 2012 à 19 ans
ils ont choisi deux voies différentes
mais avec une même arme le fleuret pour
atteindre le haut niveau cédric est
resté fidèle à trappe et continue ses
études à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin il pointe désormais au 25e
rang mondial pour sa dernière saison
junior Jéromine elle a intégré le pôle
espoir féminin français à ex en Provence
à l'âge de 15 ans et prépare le concours
de Science Po par correspondance de
systèmes d'entraînement et de vie qui
n'ont qu'un seul but intégrer l'équipe
de France en vue des Jeux Olympique de
2016 de tous les enjeux non je pense pas
parce que l'important c'est quand même
les seniors essay de rentrer à l'p c sa
j' plus comme essay de montrer ce que je
suis capable enfin aux entraîneurs
nationaux tout ça tout ça mais j'essaie
de pas trop me prendre la tête je
travaille pour l'équipe de France senior
pour pour avoir des titres pour tout
depuis le cataclysme des derniers Jeux
Olympiques de Londres où l'équipe de
France est rentré bredouille la
Fédération française est en plein
chantier des changements qui pourraient
profiter aux jeunes espoir traapiste les
main les portes elles sont ouvertes quoi
ils ont des choix à faire dans dans dans
leur vie voilà est-ce qu'ils veulent
faire du haut niveau ça demande des
sacrifice ils le savent faut qu'ils
prennent leur destin en main quoi c'est
ouvert il y a rien de fermé s'ils sont
bons et et s'ils le méritent les les
places elles arriveront maintenant c'est
du travail il peut se passer plein de
choses quoi il peut se passer une
blessure il peut se passer euh
ça marche pas une année à la base
c'était pas gagné que pour l'équipe du
florédam elle devait pas partir au Goo
donc c'est c'est un super bon point
qu'elles soit parti et qu'ell aent fait
4e c'est c'est pas elles ont pas fait
dernière de la compète en même temps et
pour nous les jeunes ça nous ça n ça
nous pousse à redoubler d'effort et pour
pour pour apporter d'autres des
médailles au prochain Go je pense qu'il
y aura du changement du coup je pense
que si je me débrouille bien jusqu'au J
je pense que j'ai mes chances
après vu qu' quand même de la
concurrence à
côté pour ça compliqué mais je
vais que l'avenir se joue maintenant
pour C il s'p des meilleurreia en stages
cé des champions du monde italien c'est
s cette ouverture qui permett au espoir
tricolor de comprendre les exces du ha
niveau